where's popping it's the kid brs cash
check me out on the bootleg cal show
interview late night the late night vibe
my god
yo he got the champagne man i know you
know this this is a little uh moscato
you know what i'm saying i'm a wine i
respect that
philly shout out to the you know who
else is the big wine drinker is e40
for real oh my god that guy's we got to
connect on something
on a little tasting or something he got
his own wine i heard it's all just from
this idea he got his own wine
yeah i definitely got to try that out if
you ever go into a green room at an e40
concert
it's like that box of wine that cheap
box of wine from walgreens
so that's what's in there that's all he
that he'd be on that he'd be on that
wine bro
well look hey you haven't been paying
attention we got a a special guest here
inside the blue light cast show
blackhead podcast brs cache is here
ladies and gentlemen let's go man be
honest cash checking in all the way from
atlanta i'm on the west coast
kell what to do what's up man so uh
first of all
shout out to atlanta we were just
talking you guys are being wide the [ __ ]
open out there
so wide open wide open
was it ever even a thought process to
wear a mask out there at any point in
time
um for a little bit well let me we was
on lockdown for like a month
a good month the first just a month yeah
that was it and then after that you know
we right back outside
it ain't really affect us like that
right we different breed
yeah i mean i i would i yeah for sure
yeah let me ask you this what is rank
the atlanta strip clubs
because i'm not going to lie shout out
to magic city
i went to magic city thinking that that
was like the mecca right
and the wings were very very okay right
right they weren't great
it was i felt like i was a little
disappointed for sure now the blue flame
that's what i'm just going to tell you
blue flame was was different
that was different and then there was
another spot we went to i can't think of
the name of it
but it was uh we went to two we were
scared of like kind of like
in between it was in between if you if
you went to
you said magic city you went to the
flame did you go to uh
ace of clubs it was um it went cheap
it was right off the freeway right with
champagne
diamond club diamond club i think yeah
diamond club yeah
yeah and then and then um jaren benton
you know jaren benton is he's a rapper
from out there
not for me he's a sick [ __ ] he took me
to the strip club where there was
midgets and old ladies
he just said oh that sounds like some
unfortunate industrial you know what
that strip club is called
it's like the legendary what's it called
claremont lounge
clear mode where is it it ain't no
industry
oh okay okay it was old ladies and
midgets
i only want to go to i almost felt like
it might have been the best place i've
ever been to
so was it kind of like was it kind of
like it was a fetish or something like
i felt like it was the kind of place
that juggalos would go to you know what
i'm saying
you know what a juggalo is i know what a
gigolo is no juggalo
juggalo is somebody who listens to
insane clown posse
just just just hey if he ever gets a
booking request to do the gathering of
the juggalos turn it down
turn it down turn it down all right yeah
juggalo no
i'm just gonna put it in my book of nose
you know who the insane clown posse is
no
over my head i gotta just show you bro i
gotta show you
it's like it's like the trashiest of
white trash
like music ever made yeah and they're
and they're but their fans are like
insane people who like they have like
tattoos of them all
it's wild bro these are oh it's like
basically like a coat
yeah look at these [ __ ] guys bro
it's it's quite possibly
bottom bottom five percentile of rap
music everything's
entertaining though like i can see why
folks were like yeah they sell
shits on a merch and in the 90s they
were i mean you know independently they
made a lot of money oh yeah
i could see why though that's something
that i would just like if i was at home
when i was bored like i'd definitely
search them
and be entertained it's entertaining
yeah yeah that's what music is
entertainment 100
man well hey you've you've uh you've had
a great uh you know
last seven or eight months hey throat
babies uh
i feel like in in the uh climate of
cancer culture
and sensitive ass woke ass [ __ ]
that get offended about every single
thing
a song about swallowing is is was needed
yeah it was needed on my end like that
that's definitely why i made the song
like it i'm tired
i want to be like you we got a song on
the radio about sucking dick and
swallowing this
is it's for the culture you know what i
mean it's for the culture
we needed this thank you man hey
thank god you really think huh well
thank them
for inspiring me because it was just and
then the i just like how
flagrant the remix video was it felt
like i was in 2002.
man edgar edgar is my guy
man hey man eric who went crazy with it
yeah so
was that his idea like uh you know that
it was just a lot going on yeah you know
the video could have been on only fans
yeah yeah it definitely could have
uh tiana trump tiana trump did you bang
you know real players you know i'm
saying we don't really you know speak
too much
well she she you know she's openly she
ain't saying
she's definitely been around the block
in hip-hop and she would
she told us this during our interview
she was like r b
singers and rappers and you know shout
out to tiana how
i mean she's a nice girl right like i've
hung out with her she's yeah she cool
she she
she down to her purse you know what i'm
saying she got a lot of got a lot of
energy were you a fan of hers prior to
like having her in the video
were you a fan of her work i've seen a
couple of her um
a couple of her videos on masterpieces
and i
and i can't say that i was inspired by
it yeah if you just go to her twitter
page like she's got like this
video pinned at the top only only got to
go to twitter you just go to pornhub
type her name in yeah yeah she's a
champion for sure man
for shows yeah are you like a like a
like a would you consider yourself a
connoisseur of erotic cinema
oh yeah who's i like i like watching i
like watching
i don't do it as much now because you
know because you're out here getting
something you know yeah but
you know back in the day i used to be a
real big fan of a big fan of pinkie
you know the thing about pinky well
first of all she might be a [ __ ] you
think so
no no hey
hey listen i ain't gonna lie i had when
i was 17 i was stroking off to pinky too
but she could be a [ __ ] she built like
a little [ __ ] [ __ ] she stubby
she's stubby as a [ __ ] so
[ __ ] legend she could have been at
the lounge
hey pinkie's a legend there's pinky
there's chair remember cherokee
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah i remember lacy
duvall i don't know about lacy though
charles hamilton made a song about it
but i used this this is what used to
bother me the most
can you know when girls used to be in
school they ain't really know too much
about porn but they always used to hit
you
oh you got that mr marcus like man what
i got oh but they know who misses mr
marcus hey let me tell you something you
know you know you got a problem when you
know
all the dudes names too mr marcus
shaw michaels we i mean [ __ ] what
[ __ ] brian pumper
hey i saw brian pumper at a boba tea
place
getting into a goddamn 1998 toyota
corolla
with with what looked to appear to be
every single one of his belongings in
the back seat
oh man this was like two years ago and i
was like
i'm with my wife and i'm like oh [ __ ]
brian pumper what's good
he need one tank top on he got his fake
chains on my man jumped in a [ __ ] 98
corolla bro
then i cheated my boy that that guy he
turned out laurence fishburne's daughter
bro
like you remember that
oh man have you subscribed to any
only fans accounts oh yeah i got a
little um
i really been blessing with me you know
what i'm saying there you gotta be like
look at that
yeah i got a secret account that i i
really like if she
hot down if i hop down on the first
thing i do is i go see if she got the
only fan and she do you know i'm
subscribing so when you say hawk down
you mean like y'all checking each other
out yo like i hop down like
what's up with you you know what i'm
saying so i see if she got the only fan
i subscribed by the little the best the
best thing to buy is inside the dm
the stuff that be on the page right i
heard that you know i'm saying ain't
really talking about that you got to
really spend that hundred dollars
and fifty dollars to get that real good
video on your deal
so you're not you're not below spending
a good 150 to get the dm
oh i'm blessing you know what i'm saying
i don't i don't you support what i'm
doing all the point what you doing i
respect that man
let me ask you this you would obviously
[ __ ] a girl who's got an only fans
account
what would you date a girl who's got an
only fan's account
see i ain't never been like the the the
jealous type or you know i'm saying i
don't really care what nobody else think
because
that's her hustle so just because she
got to hustle don't mean like that she
liked it
24 7. right she might like to express
herself through her on these fans you
know what i'm saying but that don't mean
like that she
you know what i'm saying so we're
calling it expressing themselves yeah
they're expressing it so i respect what
i'm saying
i see i could i could my wife always is
like let me do a foot page
no one will ever even see they pay they
pay good money for the flip pages
i think in my feed who is that somebody
made a good
amount of money now for free i i want to
say it was woah vicky
probably ugh yeah i want to say what
vicky she made
okay so if woe vicky didn't have
all that [ __ ] on her face she would be
the kind of [ __ ] to go to an insane
clown posse concert
for real that's what their fans look
like her minus all the makeup
i don't even know what she look like i
mean she just looked like a regular like
she looks like she drinks mountain dew
and has fox racing wife beaters on when
she goes to sleep i gotta go
i gotta go check out and see if she
looks i see i seen what she look like
like twice but i don't really know too
much though
i didn't know she was still a thing i'm
glad she's not anymore to be honest that
was a bad look for us white folk you
know i mean
oh man some white people make us look
crazy
that [ __ ] was wonderful hey man my
white bootleg cab is off the chain man
you know got no citizen
i'm trying to keep my phone
oh man
hey you know you i feel like you've
probably done the same interview 58
times by now right hey throw baby tell
us about the [ __ ] song
[Music]
man you got me you got me while i don't
own a little bugs too
yeah it's good man it's good what what
have you done um
you know obviously do you feel any
pressure having the record as big as
throw baby because
it's it's it's a record that's obviously
kind of gotta not like
i don't want to call it a novelty record
this is a fire record but it also
obviously has like a novelty kind of
like angle to it
because people are the throat baby it's
kind of a thing now you know
um and it's a big record man
you know you know sometimes when when
one of your first records is that big
it could be a gift and a curse do you
feel like any pressure like you know
follow it up
i don't feel i don't feel no pressure
because the same way i made it i was
just
having fun doing my thing doing
something i love to do and
i do that every day you know what i'm
saying so i got a lot more records
that's
inside of that same boat right they just
it ain't been released yet i'm just
waiting on the right time to just unload
them
facts uh you so talk about like your
influences
because coming out of atlanta there's so
much
you know i always tell everybody atlanta
i don't think anyone's ever had
hip-hop i don't think new york had
hip-hop longer than atlantis at hip-hop
but they had it from like [ __ ] what
79 to like 93.
and then la took it and what this
atlanta's had it since like well [ __ ]
2000
2001. it's been like 20 years bro
but like and you know between that and
then obviously so much amazing r b
coming out of
atlanta like who are some of your
influences um
well like one of my first influences
didn't even come from atlanta
somebody from atlanta had picked them up
but like bow wow like growing up
yeah i used to listen to a lot of
bioware like i wanted to rock the braids
everything like that um nelly
of course outcast android 3000 bit boy
you know what i'm saying rahim the dream
um then growing up getting a little
older i started listening like future
chris brown came out when i was in
middle school and like i got attached to
him i started listening to our chris
brown music so
yeah bow wow was um for for me
i'm pr i'm pretty sure i'm the same age
as bow wow
so i'm not sure if i was just jealous
that he was like rapping and i wasn't
right or if i was too busy listening to
wu-tang clan and like
goody mob and [ __ ] okay i you know but i
was never i was never big on bow wow but
i was beat by my friend no i mean he ran
106 in park you'd watch 106 probably
five
a new [ __ ] bow wow song every [ __ ]
song is he hosting it every other day
like he was running [ __ ] up that's why i
had it
and i think it's kind of dope cause like
he's obviously a legend and i think it
was dope to see uh drake give him
some some love you know like that was
surprising that was surprising to me
when i seen drake dude
yeah cause you know we think about how
he's
he's had some memeable situations oh
yeah for sure
you know that there's life at the end of
the day yeah but like you know for sure
you know you got to give it up to bow
wow you know the same thing same thing
with someone like soulja boy like
oh yeah yeah soldier boy's a walking
meme low key
but you can't you can't discredit him
for what he done did though
a hundred percent man was one of those
and then bowed was active he should have
stayed with that acting [ __ ] though man
you ever considered like would you ever
get into acting oh yeah i i
i always think about acting and just
expanding my brain
like i want a model i'm going to do out
it what kind of modeling
not only fans of course i'm not only a
fan but i can see myself on like a cabin
clients on cabin clown boxes or
something like that
um i see that do you remember back in
the day everyone in calvin klein ads
looked like they were on heroin
see i ain't really look at it back then
yeah i just started checking it out
today it's pretty crazy i
really i ain't even only like i had a
pair of cabin clown bosses back in the
day yeah
i said hey i was kind of scared of
calvin's blind boxers back in the day
because i would just see the like
magazine ads it's like everyone look
like dope fiends bros
i ain't seen it though have you been
binge watching any tv
during the pandemic or like what do you
watch ah man um
so i didn't caught up on the walking
dead like i like all the series
how many seasons because yo i have
stopped after noon i didn't get no i
said i just stopped i stopped around
like season seven i said this [ __ ]
getting out of hand like how many times
are these [ __ ] going to find a
place where they're comfortable
yes and then some outsiders it keeps
happening over and over
it started getting good though even
though it was kind of like repetitive it
started getting better and better and
you like
dang bro the last season i watched was
the one where the um
the what's the do with the baseball bat
negan negan [ __ ] up
um what's the asian dude's name oh
not jake um that [ __ ] though actually
had me heartbroken they [ __ ] him
up yeah they killed him yeah his head
was all blown out
[Music]
do you watch the other walking dead the
uh fear of the walking dead
because there's two separate shows now
there's the uh i think fear the walking
dead is kind of like a
oh wow it's a spin-off yeah i heard that
one's fire
and i didn't watch that one you watching
i watched the reason what about snowfall
i i started snowfall like one time but
see lately i ain't really been having
the time to just eat you're just busy
being a superstar doing shows and [ __ ]
man yeah i ain't had time to like really
just relax
yeah um was there somebody who you
wanted on the remix to throw a baby that
you could that you didn't get on the
remix or maybe it didn't come together
in time
um
that would have been crazy i ain't been
too late did she like record the verse
i don't think she got to the verse but
by the time it was already
it was already locked and said so cardi
b was
but wanted to get on the remix i don't
know she wanted to i reached out i
reached out to him but it was looking
like it was a possibility it just didn't
happen it was definitely a possibility
that would have been a perfect fit man
yeah yeah but you know it kind of came
together better than what he did
i feel like you now have a song that's
like up there with like akanellis put it
in your mouth
as far as like best like songs about
giving head
ever there's shauna getting some head
yep there's noriega
eight head which is on the nre album uh
you know and now there's throat baby
yeah it feels good
it's in a it's in a it's a whole new
world at times
or because like sometimes you don't want
to [ __ ] you just want to get ahead
you don't want it it's all but see in my
in my situation it was a little
different though
because i didn't really like head like
that you didn't like head like that uh
who did what was it first of all that's
what's going on there
i mean it just went they weren't talking
about nah you just didn't have the right
broad huh see
it wasn't even it was like with me like
i'm the type of person that like
i gotta feel some type of way about you
to even like be stimulated
so it was just a lot of stuff that would
just spur at the moment like okay we
finna do this
and then get it out the way just me
looking down it was just like
no i don't like her but for when to look
down and then it it
it made me feel some type of way i'm
like okay i'm stimulating
you know i'm saying she made me feel
this this what i've been missing
and i had to make a song about what i've
been missing hey
i know you're watching the interview
right now thank you for watching we
gotta interrupt this for a special
uh announcement from our good good good
sponsors over at odd socks
i have all socks on my feet as we speak
these are nwo socks you know i mean the
wolf pack you know somehow
shout out to um odd socks though if
you're watching this
go to oddssoxofficial.com and buy the
most comfortable socks in the world
and i truly do mean that these right
here these are the most comfortable
socks in the world
these are the basics they're just plain
[ __ ] great
you know they got all the licenses
spongebob wwe
just everything you could ever want yeah
i mean i'm just throwing socks at nico
blitz right now our producer is filming
this
but uh look go to oddssoxofficial.com
trust me they got the masks the boxers
everything you need my personal favorite
that i've been loving
is they got the naruto and i'm not even
into that [ __ ]
but the socks are fly and the street
fighter socks crazy licenses
oddssocksofficial.com keyword bootleg
kev
right now save 20 off at checkout so
you're the kind of person that like you
need some sort of uh connection with the
girl to like really
yeah i can't just
be out here touching any and everything
hey that's good man
more people should have that uh you know
that approach to life
what is something that you look for in
in a woman like that you would take
serious we just really just got to have
that vibe and that connection like if we
got that connection
then everything it's locked itself but
a lot of people with my lifestyle they
can't really like
just lock with me like that because they
always think i'm doing something else
yeah well when you say your lifestyle
what do you mean just being on the road
being an artist
on the road from city to city you know
what i'm saying being here being there
and
it's always like no matter what's going
to always be somebody that look better
than you somewhere they come up they
come along and some folks just can't
cope with it yeah it's like you got to
find a girl
very uh secure with herself right you
know
because if you're going to date an
artist you're going to be around hoes
you're going to be
you know 24 7 but the artist got to be
secure too because when you're on the
road you still can think like
oh i ain't there so she's probably doing
something else but i ain't never been
that tight
you know i just live my life and do what
i do
uh for people who have never been to
atlanta let's say we're going to atlanta
give me the one place you would take
someone to eat in atlanta
one place i would take somebody to eat
would be
um
that's a good question because usually i
would go to cheetah
cheetah yeah that's the strip club right
yeah yeah i heard they got good food
that's kind of like a strip cause i
don't even call it a destruction i heard
is that the club that's kind of like uh
they they like the type of club that
kind of plays like nickelback and [ __ ]
in there
yeah but they got good food but they got
good food and they dance like but
there's a [ __ ] in there
dancing look at this photograph yeah
yeah they're dancing like
uh awful oh grand theft auto yes
that type of dance auto dancing bro
i don't even go for the little dance i
go for the eat yeah
yeah it's funny because people are
trying to get me to go there they're
like yo don't go there for the strip
club go there to eat
all right they got good luck is it lamb
they're the lamb that's popping the lamb
chops
the chicken though you gotta get the
chicken breast the fried chicken breast
fried chicken breast yeah yeah i think
it's just hard for me to go to like any
club where a girl will be dancing
possibly to creed
like you gotta really just turn your
back and not eating pads
yeah so cheetah so cheetah is like this
the food is that good
yeah yeah cheetah
five stars fire we gotta make it
hey amir we outside now you got hey you
got the you got the vaccine
you got the vaccine yet no oh yeah i
gotta go get i get i get caught
24 7 though 24 7 you get covered that's
it that sounds like everybody
everything i gotta do anytime i gotta go
and sit and do something like i gotta
get a coach
would you get the vaccine i mean i would
because my mom she worked for like
lab court right so she had to be the
first to get it and she got both doses
and she's good my sister good my god i
got one dose i got to get the second
dose tomorrow
oh yeah you good man yeah you still here
i'm yeah
i'm just i'm just ready to get i mean i
i
caught this [ __ ] have you caught it yet
no no i got that [ __ ] in
june and ever since then i got it i got
past it and i just been
see i felt like even if i did have i
felt like i had it before they even like
knew what
it was you know what i'm saying because
i had came back from from new york one
time
and i just felt like i was sick but this
was before lockdown anything
and i was in the house for like a good
week straight but after that week you
know
i was back good let me ask you something
when you go to new york
do you have the same like feeling that i
might have like i could never [ __ ]
live here
yeah yeah i couldn't live here okay i
just make sure i'm not i can literally
we just spent the whole week in new york
literally just got back today
the whole time we're there we're like
hey for real
much love to new york and [ __ ] but i
could never [ __ ] this [ __ ] it'll push
you while you're walking on the street
the whole [ __ ] is just too much
the whole like just the thought of like
driving a car there
yo it's like why am i like what
why would people choose to live here why
don't they move to atlanta
or no no no anywhere else don't move
don't move to atlanta
everyone's moving there yeah you know
hey is that frustrating to like live in
the city where every rapper is kind of
moving to
in the last year i feel like everyone i
i know is like living there at the
moment
and it's crazy because it's like we used
to can just like
before five o'clock you know you knew
traffic would come in at like six
o'clock it was the second time for
traffic now man traffic be it like 12
30. really yeah oh that's some la [ __ ]
i'd be like man
like i know i can't go nowhere i gotta
move early early
do you you live like within the city
because i know a lot of people live on
the outskirts
oh no no i'm out you're out yeah i ain't
not in the city
yeah like t-pain lives like an hour away
from atlanta but it's still technically
like
and then i got homies who live in
gwinnett county oh yeah
that's the north side that's the north
side yes yeah yeah
that's out of skirts that's where the
migos are from right
yeah i heard they were from the north
side yeah
i don't really know um so you you got an
ep that's out
cash only out right now that's how uh
i'm assuming that there's an album that
is being worked on
oh yeah we cooking up in the process
right now
a lot of legendary stuff on how many
records do you have that are like kind
of like okay this is for the album these
are album worthy
to be truthfully like a good 30. 30 of
them we couldn't
you can't really like decide where we
just knew like
okay we're gonna put this on this but
we're gonna save this
but it's like we keep saying we're gonna
save songs and songs and
by the time we know it's just building
up in the photo and we like okay we
can't put all these on them
right beyond the separate what is your
um writing process cause you know some
people they just
you know go in and they'll like do that
do do kind of do the melody then do the
punch in
and you know maybe not necessarily write
stuff down like like how do you how do
you write
um i might be at home and then i
listened to a beat and i just started
writing
you know so you like putting stuff in
your phone yeah yeah my whole my whole
phone
you do the voice note with the melody
yeah yeah yeah i do out of it
and then i actually go to the studio i
don't really like going to the studio
wasting time
trying to like you know with stuff on
the spot yeah but a lot of artists will
they'll book like eight hours and maybe
two of them will be actually
recording only youtube yeah cause you
know i own a recorder studio we're here
right now right sometimes
it looks like i'll be in here uh
you know and i the homies will just be
in here
doing drugs and drinking and i'm like i
mean i'm not tripping because they're
paying me you know right but it's like
like you said like i don't like doing
that like when i go to the studio i go
to strictly like work get it done
and all like everybody being in my
session i really just like smart man
because you gotta work man listen the
studio time costs money
yeah for sure not so busy it's coming
out your budget so you gotta recoup that
[ __ ]
facts well hey look it was nice to talk
to you man
i hope that this was one of the best
interviews you've done so far
oh yeah you read down the earth real
flat guy yeah that kid is my dog
for sure
we couldn't do the zoom [ __ ] because i'm
so tired of seeing you on every radio
dj's [ __ ] instagram live oh like that
and then
the quality don't need it don't even be
right i'm like damn
y'all i told i told amir and brian gaffi
i said look man when he's in la we
he could pull up for sure and i
definitely appreciate that
i like this better like man hands on in
person sure man listen um go get the ep
and the album is on the way yeah it's
only out right now they see us streaming
that cash out featuring mulatto
feel better featuring tucsi and of
course the throat baby remix featuring
the city and
uh uh city girls and the baby hey um
what's like the new single
the new single what's the new single
cash out future mulatto okay okay so
look introduce
the new single just be like yo what up
this is brs cash here's my new single on
the boulet calf show
well it's poppin it's a kid brs cash you
finna get ready to listen to that cash
out featuring mulatto right here on the
bootleg kev show let's
get it perfect